the show now is our friend from
pointsvet senior editor teddy greenstein
teddy good to have you with us uh let's
talk a little bit about the lines and
where we can expect things here for week
number one uh week one the rams giving
seven points the over under at 45. so
where are we supposed to bet on this
first sunday night of the nfl season
well catherine i live just a few miles
from soldier field so i consider myself
an expert on crummy quarterback play
and since aaron rodgers has been in
green bay since he's really taken over
since 2008 the bears have used 14
different starters and of course they
entered this season with so many
question marks andy dalton is the week
one starter 99 of the fan base wants
justin fields and that uncertainty is
part of why i like the rams here i think
they have a huge advantage at
quarterback with matthew stafford now i
will say this as well if you like the
rams flock to points bet here because a
lot of books have this line at seven and
a half seven in the hook in betting
parlance
we have it at seven points what's
unusual about that is it has not bunched
since our line came out in may even
though eighty percent of the money we're
taking on this game so far
has been on the ram so our traders are
baiting you into betting on the rams and
i will take that
okay i like it i like that all right you
know teddy we always love a flare for
the dramatic what are some of the season
exotics that you're going to be looking
at
yeah so the exotics are really fun
unless you are a fan of one of the teams
uh that might be the last to register a
win and that's what we're going to start
out here so the lions are favored at
plus 250 the texans are at plus 350 and
we have a whole mess of teams at plus
one thousand now the texans open at home
against the jaguars so even if you're
not a huge tired tailor guy i think you
have to pass on that team the lions
certainly have the schedule to win
this bet when you look at the schedule
of 49ers packers ravens and then at
chicago at minnesota i am going to take
my beloved new york jets at plus 1000 at
10 to 1. sort of going for a reverse
jinx effect here now the jets play the
falcons week five but maybe by then the
lions will have shocked the world all
right just fan living in chicago we'll
get to that another episode down the
road but teddy nfl kickoff dallas
cowboys at the tampa bay buccaneers the
game line the buck's currently seven and
a half point favorites over under at 50
and a half what are you thinking about
this
yeah now i hate to be a total goober and
go with the favorites like so many
amateur bettors do while the uh more you
know experienced bettors talk about the
value in the underdogs but but here we
are now before we get to my pick i do
have to tell you about one thing
juice so the juice is basically the tax
that sports books put on these games and
the standard wager is minus 110 you
wager 110 to 100 at point sped for the
entire month of september we are
offering no juice lines they are going
to be posted 48 hours before kickoff
that means you bet 100 to win 100.
pretty extraordinary now in this case i
am going for the favorites for the bucks
because of a couple trends one the
cowboys were the worst spread team in
the nfl last year they went five and
eleven always overvalued and two the
defending super bowl champion this is
pretty remarkable fourteen six and one
against the number since 2000 i think
you'll recall a year ago the chiefs
covered in their opener against the
texans
so i think there's too much uncertainty
in big d with that prescott and his
shoulder and the bucks are so solid
nearly the same roster that dominated
the chiefs in the super bowl last year
that's good enough for me yeah which is
kind of scary if you think about it all
right teddy we look forward to having
you on and always breaking things down
for us the nfl season is almost here and
the nbc sports predictor app has you
covered sunday night 7 is free to play
with a 100 000 jackpot up for grabs
every week you can download today from
your app store or visit nbcsports.com
predictor
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports